Spain is on the brink Madrid has
reasserted full power over the once
autonomous region of Catalonia and is
charging its independence leaders with
rebellion which could mean up to 30
years in prison the unprecedented events
have sent shockwaves through the region
where tens of thousands of Catalans on
both sides have been taken to the
streets for months we came here to learn
why Catalans are fighting either to
remain part of Spain or to break away
I'm in Barcelona the capital of
Catalonia where the push for
independence from Spain has drawn tens
of thousands of people to the streets
and divided friends and neighbors the
battle over Catalonia dates back to 1714
when the region was defeated in war by
what is now Spain it became one of 17
autonomous communities in the
decentralized country with its own
president parliament and police force
but for decades there's been resentment
building over Madrid's interference in
the region and in 2008 as Spain fell
into a deep economic crisis the modern
movement for independence gained
momentum this fall catalonia's
parliament announced it would hold a
binding referendum on whether to leave
Spain
Madrid's that such a vote was illegal
and in violation of the Spanish
Constitution and on referendum day Spain
sent its militarized police to shut
voting down sparking outrage on the day
we arrived in Barcelona anti-fascists
were protesting the crackdown this
protest by the antifa has now been met
by a police line who are blocking them
from going any further they're out here
protesting the police violence that we
saw on the day of the referenda the
crowd was also anti media so we spoke to
student members of the Catalan National
Assembly a pro-independence civic
organization that was one of the driving
forces behind the referendum how did you
guys feel on the day of the referendum
October 1st when you saw the Spanish
police and government respond with such
brutal force
shock muy grande 1 in total animal
fiona's they are revered in potentia the
de non-tender por que un movimiento que
des their principles I see the Pacifico
secret endure a premier content
Eton dismiss Radha consent Emma your
inclusive way already de estadística
Yama's a mobile vista Fiona's la gente
single marathon is but other thing there
so the ritual affiliate for Mona Theon
in the end voter turnout was around 43%
but of the 2.3 million people who voted
almost 90% chose to leave Spain recently
sacked Catalan president Carlos
Bustamante said the results meant the
region had won the right to independence
that sent thousands of Catalans to the
streets to protest against secession
no tenemos que tenemos que tenemos la
unión for completed a total Pueblo
[Music]
Madrid's forceful response has conjured
for some memories of Spain's recent
fascist past under military dictator
Francisco Franco who ruled from 1939
until his death in 1975
[Applause]
and it's drawn people from far ends of
the political spectrum to the streets a
member of a far-right group told us she
supported the police response and
thought Madrid hadn't gone far enough a
super a via ferrata policy on a comment
another yet any local delicacy hace para
que gobierno community of the secular a
unit throughout Barcelona people display
political leanings with flags hung off
balconies here catalan flags are more
common than Spanish ones since the
lead-up to the referendum
they've also hung flags that say yes to
independence
Catalans have their own language and
unique traditions like these castells
or human towers under Franco these
practices were suppressed so this is a
major symbol of Catalan identity and it
represents everyone in society coming
together and building together quite
incredible to witness them as you can
tell it's a major tourist attraction
[Applause]
Catalonia was granted official autonomy
in 1932 but that was revoked in 1939 by
Franco when he seized power it was
restored several years after his death
when Spain transitioned to democracy
Carlos Castellanos was jailed several
times for resisting Franco and fighting
for independence
his grandson Raja has inherited the
cause because well as well feelings or
nobody in my own neighborhood in
Barcelona for demanding liberation I was
in
they live in Girona a tourist
destination that's a cradle of the
separatist movement it's also the
birthplace of Poosh de menthe who was
the mayor before he was catalonia's
president why is the issue of Catalonia
one of injustice for you promote around
them so the representative is that
political fit la moneda the faith not a
massive anomaly the museum in and
Espanyol the Rannells the Horizonte
would perceive another general miss the
lace no problem in de Catalunya the de
casa la Justicia sociality like Walter
from linear control or mafia was in
place two days devoted on the internal
Madonna's laser photographers yet
luckily the refuge's what some people
say make a move at all or member lale
control a particular row marquee events
to the Xolos paniolo was a preemie
have either of you ever felt that you
are Spanish say melon woman named
enchancia mojo bunyan possess a person
Alice pan young kitten is when an empire
lonnis yo Spinola a spoon amento and lay
in position as yoga steady on oh yeah
gasps italiana a lot there's no seams de
la Peninsula nobody very mum said even
national espanol una daddy Bulgarian
position flowers commemorating the
violent police crackdown on referendum
day hang at the school where we met
which was a polling station
[Music]
[Applause]
your important important in relation to
wireless connection anakin is la la la
mañana en español en espanol militar
neighs de la dama de gracia castellana
military on October 27th catalonia
officially declared independence from
spain
soon after Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy
announced that under Article 155 of the
Spanish Constitution Madrid was
dissolving Catalonia's government and
calling a snap election members of the
Socialists party of Catalonia had walked
out of Parliament in protest before the
vote for independence
we spoke to organisation secretary
Salvador allarakha before the dramatic
turn of events
he told us independence leaders had no
right to defy the law should the Spanish
government implement article 155 of the
Constitution if mr. Poojah moon doesn't
declare doesn't accept the rule of war
some step must be taken by the spanish
government to restore the rule of law in
catalonia we should be clear that
without the rule of law that is not
democracy possible explain to me why you
are against independence independence is
about for Catalan people because he
devises Catalan people into house and we
want to unify unify the cattle
population the Catalan people it's bad
because it takes us out of here oh but
we want to be part of human world and
it's bad because from an economical
point of view it's a very bad business
for the Catalan economy as we have seen
these last days with more than 500
companies to live in Catalonia
it's very clear to me from talking to
people over the past week that Catalans
are divided what do you think the best
way for it is to heal those divisions
and
to try a new agreement between Catalan
people and the rest of Spain we see that
this can be attained through a
reformation of the Spanish Constitution
and we think this can change our
consensus of let's say 70 80 percent of
the cattle population this is the most
important problem we have nowadays in
Catalonia the division in the society to
find out what it feels like to be
friends on either side of the polarizing
issue of Independence we visited the
home of our nest o Lopez arnesto and his
friend Carlos have been friends since
they were three Carlos is for
independence and Ernesto is against it i
McKay's independence because I think the
logical order of humanity is advancing
to bigger and more inclusive political
communities not smaller okay and my
nationality I think it's Catalan because
I've always been educated in Catalan
languages Catalan my costumes and my
traditions are Catalan and are different
from Spanish I love Spain I love Spanish
people but I don't think that Spain's
in that pain belongs to me with
globalization's little states and a
token Catalina I don't like Spain little
state like Spain are going to his appear
are gonna be totally irrelevant a
European Federation is only answer to
modern times we're living in because we
have big countries like the US like
Russia and China cannot compete with
them we have to be together if you want
to compete with them so is there anyone
in your life that you completely
disagree whether you're not talking to
anymore no no one at all well indeed my
my girlfriend is Spanish and she defends
the unity of Spain and we're still
together we have a great relationship
and we'll have our different opinions
but we respect each other and we love
each other that the most important thing
in the end I think and with love and
respect I think we can get along very
well and the same for Catalonia and for
Spain
at least two other regions in Spain with
separatist leanings are keeping close
watch on what's happening in Catalonia
Galicia on the border with Portugal and
the Basque Country on the border with
France which is also one of Spain's
wealthiest regions outside Spain
Catalonia has support among other
movements for local rule including
Scotland the Flanders region of Belgium
and two of Italy's wealthiest northern
regions which also recently voted in
favor of greater autonomy in a
non-binding referendum meanwhile no
other countries have said they would
recognise Catalonia statehood the EU and
the u.s. have expressed their support
for Spain what's clear is that what
happens next will determine the future
of generations to come
[Music]
hey guys it's Deena and as you just saw
the issue of Catalan independence is
pretty divisive in Spain soccer is also
polarizing and political in the next
video I'll show you how Spain's top two
teams FC Barcelona and Real Madrid are
an example of that